few modern shooters can match the
heart-pounding exhilaration and immense
strategic depth to seize each eaves with
its a symmetrical PvP with no response
no regenerated health and only five
players per team
every life suddenly feels meaningful and
precious while shooters that emphasize
twitch shooting over tactics can grow
tiresome seizures seemingly endless
array of viable strategies makes every
round memorable and organically
baguettes the kind of brilliant
unpredictable moments you can't wait to
tell your friends about there is a
campaign sized hole where the single
player should be but seizures to
compensate by adding robust training
missions called situations and by
reprising Rainbow six is thrilling
cooperative mode terrorist hunt plus
it's competitive multiplayer is
imminently replayable thanks in part to
its mixed-mode servers abundant map
variations and diverse roster of
unlockable operators because of the
games online team-based focus my
experiences weren't always perfect but
when C's works there's nothing else like
it it's not designed to appeal to all
players and that's exactly what allows
it to be something special
you